c'est un va-et-vient constant
d'ambulance militaire pour chaque soldat
soigné qui repart sur une chaise
roulante improvisée un autre établi
marqué à vie par la brutalité de la
guerre Sacha nous dit qu'il a roulé sur
une mine son confrère qui était au
volant et mort sur le coup il avait 22
ans
il y a autant d'histoires tragiques que
de blessés dans ce centre de trauma dans
le sud de l'Ukraine depuis la ligne de
front on les transporte ici et on les
soigne sous haute surveillance
l'hôpital est plein mais nous n'avons
pas le droit de filmer dans les chambres
ils sont cinq ou six soldats dans chaque
pièce qui récupère en silence souvent
après des heures sur la table
d'opération
la médecine de guerre se développe au
rythme des combats et elle fait des
miracles
ça fait trois semaines que Vitali a
failli perdre son bras gauche
une balle dans le coude lors d'une
embuscade alors qu'il traversait une
rivière la nuit pour secourir des
confrères d'armes
se sont habitués à ce genre de blessures
graves en Ukraine il promet que si on le
réparateur il retournera se battre
mentale selon lui qui donne l'avantage à
l'armée ukrainienne sur celle de l'armée
russe
des hommes motivés qui pensent leur
plaît et se relève
des blessures souvent qui ne se voient
pas mais qui les ronge à l'intérieur ce
soldat timide et nerveux nous a raconté
qu'il est soigné pour le cœur rattrapé
par le stress et la violence de la
guerre
une violence inouïe
a souffert le martyre quand des éclats
de bulles ont déchiré tous les nerfs de
l'épaule il était prêt physiquement et
mentalement mais il décrit des
conditions de combat absolument pénibles
sans manger sans dormir des combats sans
bottent mais on n'a pas le choix d'ici
et lui aussi veut à tout prix retourner
au front même si ça veut dire qu'il
risque comme tant d'autres d'y laisser
sa peau l’armée ukrainienne n'a pas
dévoilé combien de soldats sont morts
depuis qu'elle a lancé ses
contre-offensives dans l'Est et le Sud
mais Vitalis c'est trop bien qu'elle
leur coûte cher
quand il raconte avoir eu enterré des
frères d'armes dans les champs il y en a
beaucoup trop
mais la mort dit-il je ne la vois plus
comme avant
il faut plutôt voir la guerre comme
l'occasion de survivre dit Vitali il est
blessé mais pas vaincu ici Tamara
Alteresco Radio-Canada dans le sud de
l'Ukraine